hallo leute ich stehe hier mit frank
alle frank hallo manuel frank ist der
nachbar von kari und janosch und er ist
tischler von beruf tischler das ist ein
handwerksberuf davon habe ich wenig
ahnung und du hast uns heute eingeladen
in deine werkstatt ich freue mich sehr
heute etwas von dir zu lernen und frank
was brauche ich bevor wir loslegen ja
als allererstes eine vernünftige
kleidung okay bei dir da mal eine jacke
mitgebracht ja die solltest du dir
überziehen aber ist klar damit du
wenigstens etwas geschützt bist vor den
steuern und vor den spänen die entstehen
werden beim arbeiten alles klar dann
würde ich sagen los geht's
los geht
[Musik]
die werkstatt janosch und frank laufen
durch franks werkstatt
das werkzeug für viele handwerker
arbeiten braucht man werkzeug
das holz das metall holz und metall sind
unterschiedliche materialien
der hammer der nagel
mit einem hammer schlägt man einen nagel
in die wand oder in ein stück holz
der schraubstock mit einem schraubstock
befestigt man ein stück holz an dem man
arbeiten möchte
die zange mit einer zange kann man einen
nagel
herausziehen
das weil das ist so ähnlich wie eine axt
man kann damit ein stück holz in zwei
stücke teilen der handfeger mit einem
handfeger kann man eine fläche
saubermachen
die schraube der schraubenzieher mit
einem schraubenzieher schraubt man eine
schraube in das holz
der akkuschrauber mit dem akkuschrauber
geht das schrauben noch leichter
der zollstock mit einem zollstock kann
man etwas messen
die säge mit einer säge kann man ein
stück holz in zwei teile zerlegen
[Musik]
der leyen
mit leim kann man zwei holzstücke wieder
verbinden
die bohrmaschine mit einer bohrmaschine
portmann ein loch
das maßband das maßband kann man
ausziehen und damit etwas messen
das schleifpapier mit schleifpapier kann
man einen tisch abschleifen
die schraube die mutter und der
schraubenschlüssel
mit einem schraubenschlüssel
schraubt man die mutter auf die schraube
[Musik]
sofa ich bin heute dein lehrling bin
sehr gespannt was kannst du mir zeigen
und was gibt es heute zu tun manuel wir
möchten eine tür reparieren bist du
bereit dafür ich bin bereit das heißt
das ist eine tür von einer berliner
altbauwohnung vermutlich das ist richtig
genau so und was gibt es da zu
reparieren wie du siehst hier ist an
dieser tür schon etwas repariert worden
und sie möchten an dieser tür das jetzt
auch machen manuell wir möchten an
dieser tür diese schloss tasche
reparieren da ist ein neues stück holz
einnahmen dazu müssen wir etwas
vorbereiten okay
das ist eine kappsäge
die arbeitet so
ich mache ein schnitt du machst
einschnitt dann alles klar wir stellen
uns 30 grad ein
das ist ein winkel einstellung ja wir
stellen uns 30 grad ein
stopp mein gehörschutz
ich mache ein schnitt du machst einen
chat
[Musik]
jetzt einschalten oben am griff
danke bitte
das ist eine schöne für eine säge wer
wollen wir haben uns den riss gemacht
und wir werden jetzt diese china anlegen
und damit der tauch säge dort lang
schneiden
[Musik]
und woher weiß ich gleich
bis das wo ich segen soll also dass ich
mich zu viel
darauf habe ich gewartet
deswegen haben wir diese löcher hier
gebohrt ok jetzt können wir sehen wie
weit wir sägen müssen man spürt quasi
das ende dann und man spürt das nicht
man sieht es ja man sieht okay ich mache
einen kleinen schnitt vor damit die säge
die nicht hoch fliegt
[Musik]
falls du gesehen hast das ist da gefunkt
hat habe ich gesehen haben kleine nägel
drin
pech kann man nichts machen
[Musik]
so
haben einen ausschnitt gemacht ja jetzt
kommt der spannende moment passt das
stück hier rein
das wird leider nein nein noch nicht
weil wir noch nicht ganz fertig sind
das stück holz passt noch nicht ganz da
rein dh wir müssen jetzt das jahr
manuell wir werden jetzt nacharbeiten
nacharbeiten ok
manuell wir werden uns das jetzt
vorbereiten dass wir dieses stück dort
eine bleiben können wir machen uns jetzt
eine unterlage die war vorspannen und
dann darfst du leimen alles klar
das haben wir in laim und können denn
damit das holz bestreichen das darfst du
machen und dann bleiben wir das so ein
wie lange muss das trocknen danach der
bleiben braucht circa zwei stunden
einfach auf der fläche verteilen
[Musik]
naja tischler ist schon ein spezieller
beruf muss man
ja man muss halt das gefühl für etwas
haben und heute ist ein sehr schönes
produkt und und ein sehr schönes
werkzeug werkstück kunden wenn man mit
mit hingabe mit holz arbeitet der macht
es sehr viel spaß manuel das erste feine
macht dankeschön
sehr gerne ja das müssen wir das holz
natürlich gerade ansetzen
[Applaus]
das war's das was wir haben die tür
repariert repariert das heißt jetzt kann
sie dann irgendwann bemalt werden es
fehlt noch ein bisschen glas da oben im
fenster und dann kann sie alleine
abgetrocknet es wird so geschliffen und
dann ist es ein tier rowling und dann
kann sie in einer altbauwohnung eine
soziale oder auch in ein schönes café
ist eine romantische vorstellung vielen
dank frank das war sehr viel neues für
mich ich habe mich zwischenzeitlich
unwohl gefühlt aber es war ein gutes
unwohl fühlen denn ich habe das gefühl
ich habe wirklich was neues gelernt man
höchst unzufrieden dir was sie zeigt zu
haben
schön wäre wenn du mal wieder vorbei
kommst ja wo kann man sich denn finden
hast du eine internetseite wenn leute
mit dir kontakt haben wollen ja ich habe
eine internetseite man geht einfach auf
holz die berlin einfach in der in einer
suchmaschine holste berlin eingeben ok
wenn jetzt mal keinen namen wir
verlinken das unten vielen dank frank
und wenn ihr dieses ganze neue vokabular
lernen wollt dann werdet doch ein
mitglied von easy german das schreiben
wir euch auch unten in die infobox und
wir freuen uns euch bald hier wieder zu
sehen dass bald manuell ich bedanke mich
für deine hilfe und ich mich für deine
anweisungen und für alles was du mir
gezeigt hast hat sehr viel spaß gemacht
wie
wir da nie wieder